my daughters were both home from college
and and
they were living in the same room
actually my three daughters were living
in the same room in my house
and i would like walk in there and be
and say what are you doing right now
[Laughter]
and
they would
be
you know whether they whatever whatever
they were doing it wasn't it wasn't you
know productive enough for dad i felt
that right there yeah so
that's what they were talking about and
that can be that can be unhealthy right
yes like hey what are you doing right
now my kid my son used to wrestle and
then surf he's on the wrestling team on
the surf team
and so he's wrestling and surfing and
wrestling and surfing and so you'd
wrestle on wednesday and then wrestle on
saturday and you know a wrestling
tournament on saturday you get up at
four in the morning cut wait way in and
then you drive somewhere you weigh in
there you're there until eight o'clock
at night it's a total drag
then the next morning
you got to get up because the heat the
surf heat start at whatever six o'clock
in the morning so you got to get up get
load the van drive to wherever in
southern california you're competing and
surfing
so it's like all day yeah yeah two days
in a row your weekends are just
competition yeah and sitting around
uncomfortably
and so one like there was a storm or i
don't know what it was but there was no
the surf contest got canceled it
couldn't have been a storm because he
ended up going down the beach he went
down to the beach he came back from the
beach what are you doing all day
and uh you know all my family was like
dad yeah you know why don't you leave
him alone
[Laughter]
so uh that's what my daughter was
talking about toxic productivity of
which i may
and probably am somewhat of a
a perpetrator perpetrator of thank you a
perpetrator oh you're a perpetrator
confirmed you know what i will say
though like even as true as that might
be
for
that you're a perpetrator of it even how
you kind of it like
you uh just my presence yeah like it's
perpetrating but you know how you like
it's
you even like throw it on other people
or i don't know if that'd be the correct
term but you know like you're like
what have you been doing all day even
like today you did it as a joke like
what are you doing right now kind of a
thing oh early in the morning um the
it's like yo you know to me that part
becomes toxic but you do it kind of as a
joke that's what it really feels like
your kindness because let's face it
you're talk just toxically unproductive
but even though i think i think it
you when you said it to that story right
there where you're like what you've been
doing all day obviously that's funny
he's been doing a lot but then if your
daughters
have have it in them to be like leave
them alone or whatever like reveal they
know it's like okay you're even if you
are serious you're partly like yeah
not i'm not that i'm not i'm not a
psychotic about it yeah yeah exactly but
the underlyings can be heavy i know it
was heavy i know it was heavy with my
kids for sure the underlying weight of
what are you doing right now yeah that
makes sense why can't why aren't you
doing more
so when she holds your daughter the one
that's 22.
okay so
okay so when she first said toxic
productivity i was like you immediately
thought of me
yeah
i immediately thought of you yes but
with a lot of these terms especially
with the one toxic yeah like it's
it really
hits me as
the idea that yes there is such thing as
toxic whatever so we'll say productive
this toxic productivity that makes sense
and what does that look like okay does
it look like giaco okay maybe
but we do you can think of an extreme
example a perfect example of toxic
productivity we can i used to work for
and i told you this too where i used to
work for a moving company for a summer
and
they would you know they were
cool with just you working working
working they'll pay you overtime all
good like the more work you can do the
better so
toxic productivity where some guys
they'd be like hey i just want to work i
just want a bigger paycheck so they
would finish an all-day move 7 30 a.m to
like eight at night meanwhile there's
other moves going on 24 hours a day like
you know if the uh the owner of the
house or the document of the house is
gone right you just move all night right
pack up whatever so these crews
not everybody but these crews would be
like no let's go to the next shift
or to the next location or whatever just
help them move right because there's
always a move going on so guys would
work two three four days in a row with
no sleep but here's the thing they would
take math
they would smoke meth to stay up yeah
for real and look not everybody it
wasn't a common thing but there was like
there was guys and you could tell
because they'd have like little like
their lips would be burnt or whatever to
me
that struck me as toxic productivity as
a mover that is interesting productivity
and it wasn't in look i don't know
anything about the guy's life lives or
whatever but
if you're just down to work and don't
care about your body your family your
life your other parts of your life you
just want the overtime check bro that's
some solid overtime you work two three
days in a row
yeah let's not do that no no no that's
toxic so
but you do run the risk and this is you
know when you hear and let's face it
this is my weakness my generalization
weakness where when i hear a young
college student
say stuff like toxic this or toxic that
their small little idea does creep into
my head sometimes like oh you're just
applying the toxic term to something
that
you know kind of thing so if you went
that route it's like okay toxic
productivity okay so it could you could
be like someone could look at you and be
like oh you're so productive and then in
with the with the motivation of just
sort of hating on you they'll be like oh
that's toxic you know because they don't
feel they feel maybe um inferior or
something and there is let's face it
there is there can be there it'd be easy
to say that's just toxic productivity
off and monday you know right
that's
exactly exactly right where it's like
any other dichotomy you got to balance
this stuff
yeah so the toxicity marker where does
that lie on that little spectrum right
the continuum
you're you know for
i don't think yours is talking well
you might have elements of toxic if
you're pissing people off i think yeah
you know or making them feel like well
no i think what's good but well i put i
put a lot of it on myself like i do this
stuff myself yeah right so it's not like
i'm like calling you
at like hey you need to get this done
i'm not doing that sure cause yes
other than like the three things that
that you're responsible for pressing
record
showing up here
and number three uploading a video to
youtube or whatever other than those
three things i got it
you